BAGGAGE AND YOU CERTAINLY ARE
GOING TO HAVE ANY BAGGAGE IN
TERMS OF RUSSIAN COLLUSION, I
JUST DON'T KNOW HOW THAT CARRIES
OVER INTO SENATE RACES.
>> Laura: DANA, ON THE ISSUE
OF SUBSTANCE THAT JUAN WILLIAMS
BROUGHT UP, SAYING THIS IS KIND
OF A REFERENDUM ON TRUMP -ISM.
I WOULD TAKE ISSUE WITH THAT AS
BRET SAID.
GOING FORWARD WITH THE
IMMIGRATION, TRADE DEAL,
DEREGULATORY EFFORTS, JUDGES,
WHERE DOES THIS LEAVE THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY WHEN YOU HAVE
FLAY, MURKOWSKI, COLLINS AND
McCAIN MORE OBVIOUSLY ON MANY
ISSUES REALLY ON THE OPPOSITE
SIDE OF DONALD TRUMP?
>> I THINK IN MANY WAYS THE
PRESIDENT IS IN PRETTY GOOD
SHAPE ON THAT.
AS BRET HAS BEEN SAYING ALL
NIGHT, THE TAX REFORM BILL IS
GOING TO GET VOTED ON MOST
LIKELY BEFORE JONES IS EVER SET.
I'M NOT CONVINCED HE WOULDN'T
HAVE VOTED FOR ANYWAY.
LET'S SAY THEY GET TAX FROM
DONE.
THEN THE PRESIDENT IS THAT HE
WANTS TO MOVE ON AND DO BORDER
DEMOCRATS WANT TO WORK ON AN
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL.
THERE'S NOTHING HERE THAT WOULD
CHANGE THE PAST JUDGES.
I THINK I'M TRADE THE PRESIDENT
THINK A DECENT CASE TO MAKE THAT
THE END OF HIS FIRST YEAR IS
ACCOMPLISHED A LOT, PEOPLE FEEL
GOOD ABOUT THE ECONOMY AND
UNEMPLOYMENT IS LOW.
EVERYTHING IS SORT OF GOING HIS
WAY ECONOMICALLY, SO I THINK
THAT IT'S VERY HARD TO DISRUPT
THAT RIGHT NOW.
THE DEMOCRATS, THEY ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO DEFEND ALL OF THOSE
SEATS.
AS CHRIS WALLACE WAS TALKING
ABOUT, THEY MIGHT BE ABLE TO
PICK UP A COUPLE OF PLACES.
I THINK THE THING TO REALLY
THINK ABOUT IS THE CANDIDATE
RECRUITMENT.
SECOND, YOU HAVE UP TO 17, 18,
19 PEOPLE RUNNING IN SOME OF
THESE DEMOCRATIC PRIMARIES.
BUT WE SAW IN THE PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION IN 20    2016, THAT'S N
ELECTION IN 20    2016, THAT'S T
WHERE THE COUNTRY'S.
I THINK ALABAMA IS DEFINITELY AN
OUTLIER.
DO THINK VOTING PATTERNS ARE
INTERESTING TO MAYBE COMPARE TO
GOVERNORS RACE, BUT ULTIMATELY